scooby-do-be-do has a film that poo but
there's also another one
it's called Scooby Doo - and it sucks -
and I wish it was fun but it's not like
sewing Scoob this movies get a blow so
obviously we're talking about the Skippy
dude wrong room
oh shit oh you did it real
oh thank you motherfucker I can kind of
do shag we can probably cover Skippy -
movie these uh so ok so let's talk of a
film that we originally entered the
nostalgia critic on uh and then the
follow-up which we just did a psych
Perry burger kind of no reason and I
mean who knew that's when we were gonna
quit the NC again and yeah why so
everyone say I'm like are you got
quittin see you again I'm like no no we
should have juice Ike parity should have
just spread that as a rumor just to fuck
with people actually yeah we should have
done with the fun
oh but yes Terry's people you got these
scooby-doo movies I mean I grew up with
scooby-doo uh it's fine
that's somebody's how I described that
is great for kids yeah for some reason
involves a STONER a possible lesbian and
some dead zombie a neck scarf an obvious
couple that you know are obviously doing
stuff behind the scenes up but I'm
living in sin it's kind of sowing scoop
we got kicked out of the van again
what's going on in there something about
that combination though has led to so
many incarnations it's still going
there's all these different versions and
and the some about that that group so
this movie comes along then honestly
when I heard they're kind of doing a so
I could poster I'm like be kind of funny
you know kind of making fun of it again
like the Brady Bunch movie then we saw
the trailer and then we saw was Roger
Casanova who actually back then was not
known you could argue he still not know
now but he's known among the audience
we've had to see a lot of his movies um
and from what I hear with the first one
uh that it was originally supposed to be
very adult it was supposed to be like
the Brady Bunch movie
to be a say attire but kind of last
minute maybe from the direction but
that's just really mean speculation uh
they decided to make it family-friendly
and really key smell I smell as in all
things studio intervention but at the
same time I think because if this guy
did some good movies then I'd be like
all of us stinking studio like was you
oh I should probably saw it and I
thought it was both that this can't work
for adults we got to make this for kids
either that or they hired it because
they took in more adult script and they
were just like okay lame it up mmm yeah
I mean it's one up from what I heard
like you could even see with kind of the
filming there's this real cynical side
too it's a very cynical movie but it
doesn't have the comedy or the
cleverness to back it up and I wish it
did you know I think maybe they were
trying to go for the only thing I can
figure it's like a Galaxy Quest kind of
thing that's the only thing I can kind
of put together um but it doesn't work
your bad putting those two in the same
sentence yeah but it's Galaxy Quest
isn't perfect but I love that movie a
lot more yeah uh so you have this movie
written like clearly a good writer uh
you know he'd go on to do guardians of
the galaxy and stuff and you can see it
like a good funny script trying to get
out and then the second film comes along
again not that badly written like in
terms of the content it's kind of
sitting there confused and we're just
like you know this isn't a bad joke but
something's not right here like on paper
this would have looked fine but the way
it's shot and and filmed and acted it
doesn't work and that goes to the
director I'm thinking yeah that'd be a
as we've seen his other work could be a
very nice man um I just hate this movie
it's so much I'm like ooh big bowl he
could yeah very nice we don't use it to
exit oh but so the second film I think
is a little better maybe because they
knew going in okay we had to make this
half funny half for kids and again the
writers trying to get some comedy out of
it and second film was more colorful I
wound up like that being interesting the
story at all
but I was just looking at the production
design
like look very nice busy yeah this yeah
way more fun to watch than the first one
was even though the stories probably
even worse maybe technically I don't
know that it's really fucking matter
it's like you're splitting hairs by that
but what's worse scooby-doo one or two
that way but but no I do remember what
the second when we were kind of saying
like you know we can like well this
sucks but it it is better than the first
one
um because again I could at least
remember some things from it I the set
were better shown the jokes when they
did them right we're funny I remember
like there's one they had the stupid
doorbell joke
what could happen by reading a doorbell
of course they fall in this dead trap
but they see like Girl Scout cookies
Jehovah's Witnesses like all these other
people that were caught in there that's
funny then which strikes me as like that
- James gun joke like yeah like I'm like
there's good jokes tucked in here like
he was trying desperately like come on
one of these has to make it through the
Hollywood homogenizer like just well
even like even as kids jokes go some of
these are actually good like when they
get there you know there's Kimmy you
wanna buy some cookies and then next to
them next door is the Mormon saying you
know have you heard the good news and
Scooby says yeah there's cookies that's
a very cute joke that's actually very
very funny uh but it's just done so
awkwardly with everything else it's so
unsure of itself throwing in sound
effects like quick shots on ambulance
I'll give you that's a joke I'm not sure
I would use it I thought that was a good
job I thought that bright kids movie I
thought that was a good I maybe four
maybe we're moving to five girls I
wasn't too bad I was gonna say for a
very innocent joke um like that that's
cute that's a cute joke um and some I
thought the idea of them going to a bar
where all the masked people the exon
ball what a great idea that's where the
satire is coming and I'm like okay so
again I don't think you know you're
sitting to do whack the mole with the
little poopy heads they're throwing
darts at Freddie's face it is like
that's no I feel like James Gunn was
trying to kind of like lovingly make fun
of this concept and then the director
was just trying to make a movie for
toddlers I feel like uh someone was
telling us about the scooby-doo comic
that's out now that's actually
explaining why all the characters are
the way they are like Scooby was
actually
like this some sort of like CIA dog
that's given this advanced intelligence
they're kind of like these super
machines but Scooby was kind of like the
dumb one out like he was the mistake so
that's why he can't talk right a it's
not as smart and but it's heads right
over overcome that it's like that's
really clever and I feel like they're
actually can be a lot of clever things
that can be done with this idea of
taking this weird setup a kind of poking
fun at it and I feel like the second one
particularly started to do that but it
was just constantly trapped in its own
piece of crap a Hollywood system bad
directing world I don't know
so it is kind of a shame because I think
you could get some funny stuff out of
this I guess we are with some of like
these spin-offs and comics and such but
yeah it's a shame because again you can
see you know with the set design to
trying with the writing they're trying
and the design some of these monsters
and they tried to get the monsters from
the cartoons in the second one uh
there's this legit attempt it's just not
harnessed by talent ditto
I got nothing like I'm really I can't
I'm like trying to remember what
happened in the first film I'm like
Rowan Atkinson was a ghost that is all I
fucking remember and I'm thinking the
second film I'm like yeah okay I will
comment on that that was probably the
most fun I had was actually seeing the
monsters from the cartoon show come back
including the electric the ten thousand
volt guy with the Hydra mycology I said
it was a pirate in the video it's like
sighs oh I'm still kind of fascinated
that when that ship was like careening
down Broadway or whatever town is good
effect I was like you know what's scary
is these look like better effects than
the new Ghostbusters yeah yeah why don't
we throw that in yeah and I'm not gonna
like that but I've seen it for the most
part yeah yeah so that that is kind of
sad I do feel bad I didn't give a shout
out to a Scott McNealy either because
I've I've done stuff with it before and
I didn't recognize him he's the bad guy
boys you know a mystery Incorporated
I mean he's such a cool guy I didn't
recognize it's not that's a tribute to
its talent Oh but yeah I forgot to make
a joke about that oh my god apart oh man
yeah I just I've got nothin it's just
such a waste of time like I will say
this is the difference between like like
kind of like man movies that have some
moments of brilliance like I would say
the new Ghostbusters movie and
scooby-doo is I can't even talk about it
I can talk about the new Ghostbusters
movie all day what works what doesn't it
I just got nothing for this it's just it
went in one ear and out the other
so I think that the only thing that's
popped into my head I remember is that
they kind of attack this gives you an
idea of like how this could have been
funny but it's like it didn't work uh
they really attack scrappy-doo in the
first movie and everybody hates
scrappy-doo nobody liked that little
pipsqueak something that one guy you
always know it's like I don't get the
hate for scrappy-doo and you're just
like I respect you but I'm going to
chloroform you throw you in a car trunk
and leave you for dead in the little
cornfield what you really hate scrappy -
I fucking hate script now you know you
want to get me started so I'll talk
about that fucking scrappy-doo ruined
what was always a great series he is the
fucking sly he is the Slimer - the Real
Ghostbusters he was all right in a doe
sir - is like a special guest but then
when it became the fucking scrappy-doo
show
fuck that shit - oh we hate scrappy-doo
and loved the idea of making fun of him
even make him count a villain again it's
a funny idea but if you don't watch the
show you're not going to get it and even
if you do it's everything else is so
mindless and it's such fluff that when
you throw in something just so cynical
and so harsh it's like throwing this
puppy on the side of the road and he's
peeing on Daphne like all this really
weird shit it's like this doesn't
connect this really little bit with
James Gunn like that was his
contribution I'm sure yeah I mean like
that was probably the hard that the
harder-edged film he was trying to get
out and I know what it's all said and
done I feel like the best scooby-doo
spoof movie week
was at five minutes section and Jay and
Silent Bob strike back oh and I was why
we're following some dick and a fucking
neck scarf shut up your hip your old
fugitive goddamn dog and I'm like that
it hi-yah and then on that Dabney fell
more make it like that that that was the
best scooby-doo movie like and that's
the funny because that was also the only
good thing in that fucking handsome Bob
movie strike back so that's what I
thought you know could sort of make a
good scooby-doo movie that's when I kind
of got excited when I heard they're
making one that's just like no it's for
kids and it's not smart it's not funny
and like I said the only thing that we
got I think what the second way is one
or two of the jokes work and it was
visually better I just remember all the
goes in all the creature all the sets it
first it was way too cluttered it was
way too crowded with this one and knew
how to show it off more and I liked
looking I never thought I'd say this but
the by problem with the second one in
particular is it's not even a good
mystery yeah
none of that complain about the
scooby-doo mystery letting me down but
I'm like okay so it was really this guy
but you never established that we had
Mission Impossible style masks like that
so I'm like what the fuck so what why
where two masks like assuming a fun
there's no clues that connect to who the
person is and like I said in the
original scooby-doo cartoons they are
clearly for kids the mystery that are
for kids but they still establish Clues
they still have it's where they tried to
throw you Fritz Nevers it's always
assuming it is never the creepy looking
guy that looks so obviously like you
would be a monster it's always the side
character who's there for five minutes
who seems friendly enough but
mysteriously isn't really in the rest of
the episode all yeah um so that you do
catch on so spoiler alert but what I
like is that it does allow kids to still
figure it out this doesn't let kids feed
on out you just kind of have to guess
I'd just be I'd be amazed if the kids
stayed awake for the whole thing yeah um
particularly the first one the segment
of these kids might be able to get
through that better but and every adult
immediately knows who it's gonna be
in the second film obviously it's Alicia
Silverstone be there's no way around it
has to be licious or snow but then they
try to throw that extra
was no essentially this guy that we show
for a couple seconds in a flashback and
it's like lame shit that's lame and
that's cheating you let me down cartoon
mister and even with the first film
it's obviously Rowan Atkinson but then
they throw the twist they have actually
scrappy that I would have liked I would
have minded if they made it funny and
they didn't make it funny yeah uh so
yeah I forgot about that
okay well you're just reminded me of one
yeah and he turns into a monster at the
end it's like this sounds like a fishy
that job that does something doesn't it
sound funny but it was so bad I
obviously forgot it I was so poorly done
um so yeah I always feel like I this is
one of those films I just feel sorry for
James Gunn cuz clearly this is a town -
do they still love myself I don't feel
fucking sorry for him not now I would
have like I would have years ago but now
no but you know Flipboard probably
coming up like hoes while you wrote
scooby-doo way it's like it's actually
not that badly written they're not
horribly okay who's gonna come up to him
and do that because you know his reply
is gonna be like yeah and I'm doing
guardians of the galaxy - excuse me
while I light up my $100 bill fuck what
mr. Heath he is a funny writers he finds
a comeback yeah by always uh so yeah
trying to think only other thing I'll
say the impression the guys tell shaggy
especially was very good he's trying so
hard the hardest like I kept - what else
is on okay yeah they're okay but but was
Matthew weird is that who's doing that
macular does Scooby is could be shaggy
yeah he's like I feel kind of bad cuz
like man he's putting his all into it
and it's just and we notice it all goes
to waste
we know Sarah Michelle Gellar is good in
a lot of stuff bothers vamp descent
that's fuckin Buffy for what are you
doing the Buffy Freddy friends never had
any charmer enough say I don't got the
penny all you had to do is say the lines
and that's what he does he doesn't find
uh and then Velma we know went on to be
Wendy um yeah so we know she can be
funny
uh but what I think I think most of them
know how to be funny yeah um even Freddy
for sale mm man well you know we haven't
seen it in anything quite so go ahead we
just gotta
I will I will give him the benefit the
down I will put my faith in the prince
um but ya know they know this again
nothing
yeah I think that's about all we could
say if out these moves may be the lamest
one we've done I'm not probably the
shortest which for us is probably like
10 20 minutes something like that but
show it really shows you how bad you
know what you know what it shows you how
bad the movie is in not even a truly
awful way that you could just rant about
it for like an hour about how bad it is
cuz like I could do that about Canton
ahead or fucking Mamma Mia any day but
this just left no emotion no impact
nothing so maybe that's actually worse
cousin even have the honor of sticking
out as something that got off or like
gem every time you just see him at cons
anytime somebody says oh the Jim review
is so great he's like he has like a non
flashback just like fuck it you I I
gripped the fan by like the collar I'm
like I've seen things I've seen Thanks
um so what scooby-doo is not that it's
just not bad
so um yeah just bad so if you wanna see
a Scooby dooby don't cuz I'm sure no
other critic has ever made that joke so
um it was pretty forced good rock you
yes so um yeah that's about it and we'll
talk to you later
the thought occurs to be maybe your
voice is only in my head maybe I'm not
even here oh fuck